congratulations on the new show thank
you thank you my little youtube series
yeah yeah I think everything that people
don't get to see I mean they saw our
journey on the show and then they see
Instagram which is sometimes highlights
and sometimes not our complete life so
you know just the opportunity to share
everything the stuff that we're going
through a rat life moving all the stuff
is going on I think for us we just we've
completely disconnected from I mean I
hate say so we disconnected from the
show we disconnected sort of from you
know all the events and they said we
kind of just took time for ourselves we
try to get back to a normal life went
straight back to work and I think it
took a lot of patience we worked out
yeah yeah that's the biggest thing is
working at it
I mean it's like going through it listen
no I think it was the greatest thing
that I've ever done but it was for sure
tough and difficult and life not the
same when you get out of it but I
wouldn't I would say it was one of the
greatest things I've ever done
so I don't know why they say that but
it's definitely emotionally taxing know
what hey we got to hang out one night in
and out we do it off camera we do get to
do that I was begging for four weeks and
we kind of did our cellar interviews
after my hometown at the same hotel I'm
like come on just like 30 minutes 30
minutes I wish I could have spied on the
guys oh that is so great no you know
people always ask how you remember
everyone's names that first night a
little secret you don't you go you say
three names you run back to where the
producers are you look at a bunch of
photos of the guys you remember three
more names you run back out so that's a
little secret definitely didn't remember
anyone's name for the first time week we
hope like the kiss wasn't that good
[Music]
you know I hate I don't I didn't follow
as much as I should have from the stuff
that I got to see people loved him I
think he has a great story the football
guys you can talk about you a good story
yeah yeah I think he's well I mean gonna
be great I don't know that much so
hopefully he finds love this time and
not trickles through couple more girls
or a couple more shows I didn't know
it's gonna be the most dramatic show
season I'm very I mean all of them Mary
Morris Kelsea Ballerini I mean Lee I
mean all of them I I love country music
so we're excited to be here and those
are my girls let's do right there she'll
be belting out the songs for sure oh not
in pitch but with some enthusiasm good
every now and then she hits a note I'm
like okay the other day I was brushing
Carolina's tails California whatever
that one is yeah
[Music]